comment réussir la transformation
digitale de nos territoires c'était tout
l'objet des troisièmes assises du
numérique
parmi les thèmes abordés de lits santé
la sûreté urbaine dématérialisation ou
encore le numérique pour l'éducation et
cette année ces sujets ont une résonance
particulière pendant évidemment la crise
sanitaire elle confinement qu'on a
connus on a vu que le numérique prenez
vraiment une place prépondérante dans la
vie des citoyens
la première table ronde était consacrée
au numérique pour l'éducation
raccordement à la fibre très haut débit
ou achat de vidéoprojecteurs interactifs
les établissements opère un tournant et
depuis 2000 15 18 collèges des yvelines
participent à un projet pilote grâce
auquel dix mille élèves et 1000
professeurs ont reçu des tablettes à des
souhait était de travailler le passage
du manuel scolaire papier traditionnel
un ensemble de ressources numériques
dont les manuels scolaires numériques
pourquoi pas cette table ronde était
donc l'occasion entre autres de faire le
bilan de ce projet pilote qui s'achève
cette année pour les élèves la joute
d'appareils numériques comme la tablette
en plus des outils papier semble
bénéfique
la tablette leur sert pour
le recours la tablette leur sert moment
des examens aussi puisque nous avons
intégré dans l'oral de soutenance du
brevet des collèges
le fait qu'il soit en mesure de montrer
un usage pertinent de leurs outils
numériques et cela va aussi développer
des ambitions personnelles chez les
élèves
le bilan est d'autant plus positif pour
cet établissement qu'élèves et
professeurs ou utiliser la tablette
pendant tout le confinement ça nous a
permis de garder du lien véritablement
avec nos élèves et de continuer un
travail de qualité sap a juste été un
pis-aller
moi je dis souvent aux mains amusant
mais comme on n'avait pas les scories du
quotidien eh ben pour la première fois
depuis 20 ans j'ai terminé mon programme
en troisième en lettres au total plus de
400 personnes ont participé à ces
troisièmes assises du numérique